I've got a bone to pick with you
wordsmiths because this video is about
the word contentious
contentious it's an adjective
and it means involving arguing
quarrelsome we had a contentious debate
over whether bears were scarier than
snakes
kind of looks like a pig but you know
pigs can also be scary I don't know this
word comes to us from Latin contentious
and it's a combination of two parts con
which means together or with and tended
which means to stretch
to contend for something in English is
to fight for it with someone else right
you're you're stretching your
relationship with someone like a tug of
war where you're both pulling on the end
of a rope so something that's
contentious is for lack of a better word
fighty argumentative keeping those
elements con and tend in mind try to
come up with a couple of similar words
in English that contain those parts I'll
give you 10 seconds all right
Take Me Home Country Road
[Music]
here are some of mine
tension which is when something is
stretched tight like a rubber band or a
spring or it can also be a kind of
unspoken conflict between people
container a box a an enclosure of some
kind Khan Tanner means held together
and extend which means to stretch out
right to extend the hand of friendship
let's try it in a sentence over a series
of contentious meetings team cake
finally agreed to a compromise with Team
pie it must have been a bitter conflict
well I guess a sweet conflict actually
another one when we play Monopoly it's
always a contentious issue as to who
gets to be the thimble that's a weird
thing to argue over in my opinion I love
a thimble sure but you know the Scottie
dog and the top hat are right there
do not pass go do not collect 200
vocabulary words we gotta hash this
argument out first you contentious
wordsmiths you
you can learn anything
David out